I bet you didn't know that farming is as
diverse as the cultures around the globe
let's explore some fascinating
agricultural practices from the rice
patties of Asia to The Vineyards of
Europe farming isn't one size fits all
in Asia terrace rice fields Cascade down
mountainsides maximizing land use with
stunning efficiency over in Europe the
rolling Vineyards of France and Italy
produce some of the world's finest wines
cross over to Africa and you'll find
vast savanas where pastoralist herd
cattle adapting to the land's unique
challenges in the Americas you'll see
massive fields of corn and soybeans
blanketing the Midwest while in South
America coffee plantations thrive in the
High Altitude regions of Columbia and
Brazil each region uses ingenious
methods tailored to their environment
ensuring we have a variety of foods on
our tables so next time you enjoy your
meal remember the world's Farmers made
it possible want to learn more hit that
like button and subscribe to our channel
for amazing agricultural insights